大家好,欢迎观看数据要素流通技术穆克系列课程
本次课程我将向大家介绍安全协作查询研射口
我是来自马予米上科技的华国进
很高兴能以视频的形式和大家交流学习
在课程正式开始之前,有必要补充说明一下
之前我们已经在影视计算线上穆克第二期
向大家系统的介绍过了射口
本期课程则是在二期的内容基础之上
进行的更新录制
更新的点有两个
首先是部署模式的更新
二期以中心化部署模式进行了说明
本期则将基于P2P模式进行讲解
新支持的P2P模式因为不依赖可行第三方
它的部署更加灵活
其次则是实践Case的讲话
二期的实践包括中心化模式的讲解
和Secret Note P2P模式的演示
对应的模式不同意
不方便大家自行上手
因此这一期讲话的该流程
直接通过黑屏进行的P2P模式去进行Case的演示
学习过之前课程的同学建议重点关注变更部分
对中心化部署模式感兴趣的新同学
也建议回顾往期内容以进一步了解
ok
接下来我们进入到本期的课程内容
本次的课程内容主要有几下几个部分组成
第一部分将介绍联合数据分析场景
讨论该场景面临的问题和技术方案
从而引入射口
并对射口进行简单介绍
第二部分
则是深入射口的细节
介绍射口的CCL授权
射口的架构细节
以帮助大家进一步的理解和使用射口
第三部分
这是一个简单上手
向大家演示
如何通过射口完成联合数据分析任务
接下来让我们开始第一部分的内容
联合数据分析和射口数据分析概念
想比大家都不陌生
通过数据分析
我们可以从海量的数据中挖掘出
我们感兴趣的信息
是一个典型的例子
比如你要统计公司的嫉妒盈利
那么你可以通过
买射口来完成这一项任务
这一类传统的数据分析场景的特点
是数据使用方拥有数据的所有权
因此有成熟的解决方案
而在联合数据分析场景中
事情往往会变得更加复杂
再举一个例子
比如一家药厂
想联合多家医院的数据
去研究药物的疗效
但它就会遇到如下问题
因为数据分散在多家机构里面
而且高度敏感
它没办法直接是有买射过十八克等
成熟方案去进行处理
针对这种需要在保障数据安全的前提下
联合多方数据进行分析的场景
目前有两种主流的技术路线
第一种是基于可信执行环境的方案
数据拥有方需要新疆自己的数据
加密上长到可信执行环境里面
然后在可信执行环境里进行计算
说新执行环境可以保证数据的安全
这种方式统称为T1E搜狗方案
第二种方式呢
这是数据不用出狱
但是每个数据拥有方需要部署一个计算节点
计算节点之间通过MPC协议完成计算
这种方案统称为MPC搜狗方案
这两种方案各有特点
T1E搜狗的优点是效率更高
问题是数据要出狱
新鲜一个人在可信执行环境的硬件生产三分明
而且专有硬件也会带来额外的成本
MPC搜狗呢
则是用于不允许数据出狱的场景
是用通用硬件即可进行
确定是性能要低很多
可用但规模受限
搜狗采用的是MPC搜狗方案
搜狗的全程是secure collaborative query language
即核心能力就是支持多方联合数据分析
搜狗的设计初中
就是为了解决实际的业务场景
以降低联合数据分析业务的落地难度
而且也在迭代的过程当中
经历了各类业务的持续打磨
搜狗具有以下核心特征
首先在安全性上
它是基于办程序的安全模型
搜狗提供了列级别的数据使用授权控制
这是搜狗有别于其他多方数据
珍惜系统的一点
在应用性上
搜狗支持了mansego版本的
搜狗语法
熟悉搜狗语法的人可以不同NPC协议
也写出多方数据分析的query
另外搜狗支持的语法和算质也很丰富
可以满足大部分的产力需求
搜狗内置的多种数据员
包括但不限于mansego Postgres CSV的
此外还支持多个产与方
包括典型的两方三方场景
在性能上
搜狗做了很多层次的性能优化
是的性能是可以使用的
包括可以支持一级别的PSI囚交
以及千万行的聚合等等
搜狗还可以支持多种密谈协议
目前已经支持了三米两K
其他和ABYS3
用户可以根据产与方数量和性能自行选择
在了解了搜狗的基本特点后
接下来我们将对搜狗进行各深入的介绍
包括搜狗的CCL
搜狗的架构细节 关键优化等等
这些信息将对于后续安全 高效的使用搜狗进行帮助
首先我们来看CCL
CCL授权控制是搜狗的关键概率
在介绍什么是CCL之前
我们先来看看CCL是为了解决什么问题
因为搜狗很灵活
因此在多方灵活数据分析场景里面
可能存在着用户去位移勾到query来获取
原始数据的风险
比如直接select新据选出所有的数据明信
因此通常会结合4000
审核和适合审计联络手段来保证数据安全
其中4000审必需要在query资金前
获得所有参与方的审核确认
但是审核query对审核留言有较高的要求
需要具备分析query风险的能力
同时等所有参与方都审核通过的周期也比较长
影响效率
因此我们提出了基于CCL的安全保战模型
数据拥有方先设置数据的适用限制
如果select没有通过CCL检查就拒绝往下执行
审核人员只需要去检查通过CCL检测的query
从而来减轻审核的负担
此外CCL还提供了额外的好处
select可以根据用户的CCL授权对算法进行优化
在默认情况下
计算都是在全密胎下进行的
整体的算法性能不佳
但如果用户进行了相关CCL授权
这可以使用遵循CCL限制的高效算法
以显著来提升系统性能
比如如果用户设置了PanTechSaf的胶案的CCL
允许去发挤方得到交集ID
那么系统就可以通过psi算法
来替换密胎胶案的算法
计算速度可以提升两到三个数量级
接下来是CCL的具体定义
CCL的全程是column control list
它是定义了一个三元组
sauce column,desk party, or constant
表示数据拥有方允许某些数据sauce column
被某个差异方desk party
以某种约束条件进行数据访问
就比如右下角Alys拥有数据表TVA
它的serrary字段对Bob的使用约束
是PlanTechSaf's aggregate
什么意思呢?
表示Bob只能看到这个字段聚合后的结果
即通过some average max min等操作之后
才可对Bob可见
CCL是一种约束机制
使得数据拥有者可以使用CCL
描述美丽数据在使用过程中的约束
数据分析引擎则确保
所有执行过程都严格满足该约束条件
需要注意的是CCL和安全之间
不是一个线人的关系
不满足CCL约束的一定版权
但满足CCL约束也不一定安全
CCL目前定义了8种约束
比如Zantax在允许以任何形式
包括名文去进行计算和披露
没有任何使用上的限制
通常用于非民感数据
建议谨慎使用
一般来说
表的每一列对数据O都是PlanTechS
但对其他差异方
不建议设设PlanTechS
在比如PlanTechS After join
允许作为Inner join key
经过join后
可以名文披露
在比如PlanTechS After aggregate
需要列经过Aggregation操作
比如Some Average的这样子的结果
才是可以名文披露的
其他的CCL在这里就不再追溯了
大家可以自行暂停查看
然后我们再看一个CCL授权的例子
假设iList拥有表TA
报告拥有表TB
借一点ID对iList的约数是PlanTechS
TB.ID对iList约数是PlanTechS After join
这TB.ID和TB.ID的join后的结果
对于iList是可见的
而TB.column1对iList约数是PlanTechS After aggregate
TB.column1需要经过聚合操作
才可以对iList可见
因此当iList尝试执行
如下query selectTB.ID
TB.column1 fromTB
in the join TA onTB.ID等于TA.ID的时候
因为它尝试直接获取TB.column1
不符合CCL的约数就会教育不同过
然后如果iList把query改成
selectTB.column1的arrange结果
那么它就可以满足CCL的约数
获取最终的结果
接下来介绍seco的系统组成
Gilvy模式下seco系统由seco block和seco engine组成
各个参与方都需要自己部署独立的seco block和seco engine
以右图为例
iList和BobG部署了自己的seco组件
然后通过网络一起构成联合数据分析平台
集中seco block作为P2P的核心模块
主要有三个功能
首先是需要和用户进行交互
其次是负责block之间的状态同步
最后是seco的珍惜和作业调度
需要将seco的查询
转换成明明纹混合的执行图
并调度到本地的seco engine去执行
而seco engine呢
则是一个明明纹混合执行引擎
不同参与方的seco engine可以协作完成多方分析任务
本地的seco engine会将结果汇报给seco block
seco engine是在NPC框架secret flow SPO的组织上实现的
那么当seco收到用户发起的query后进行了哪些处理呢
如图是seco的详细架构
用户发起的query会捅不到所有的seco block
block首先会创建session manager
session manager会教育用户的身份信息
检查通过后
query会经过part的解析成与发数ast
接着planner将ast构建成逻辑执行计划
chance later将逻辑执行计划翻译成密探执行图
在翻译之前会进行CCL教验
只有CCL检查通过了才会进入下一步
chance later是seco的核心
它会在多种约束条件下选择最佳的协议
结合协议的特点数据状态分布选择最佳的执行逻辑
比如针对Guru带操作
seco就实现了四种协议
然后graph optimizer会用图优化算法对自行图进行优化
比如节点合并和消除等等
这里得到的图还是一张传辑图
graph splitter会将图按照参与方进行切分
每个参与方只会看到自己参与的计算节点
构成的指图
各个block只会进行指图的教验
并砸给seco engine进行执行
在进一步了解了seco后
第三部分我们将通过一个简单的case
来实际上手一下seco
结合时间来加征一下理解
假设有这样一个业务场景
金融机构埃利斯想联合第三平台bob
做联合用户的画像分析
首先埃利斯拥有User credit的表
这张表记录了用户的信息等级年龄
收入信息
bob则拥有User status表
记录了用户在电厂平台的交易额
活跃状态的
埃利斯希望统计不同信用等级下
年龄在二十到三岁之间
写为电厂平台
bob活跃用户的人数
以及其平均收入和平均交易额
通过query表达无忧图所示
那么
埃利斯bob像如何通过seco
来完成这一联合分析呢
seco的使用流程主要分为三个步骤
首先是完成系统部署
然后是进行项目设置
最后就可以进行联合数据分析了
其中项目设置还可以进一步
划分成创建项目
用户邀请数据授权等等操作
在完成这些操作之后
埃利斯和bob就可以去做数据分析任务了
接下来让我们进行实际的操作
我后续会在黑屏命令行进行操作说明
ok
接下来我将基于seco官方的快速开始文档
向大家展示一下
seco从部署到配置
然后再到进行联合分析的整体流程
seco支持两种部署架构
甚别是中性化和pdp
我们掩饰的是pdp架构
这里我们会给每个餐饮方都部署seco engine
和seco block
我的掩饰环境是macbook pro m1
当然在安装了linux系统的机器
或者虚拟机里面也都可以进行同样的操作
接下来我们参考文档开始一步一步的操作
首先是客龙仓库
如果大家之前没有用过github
可能需要去github上面注册一下账户
网上有很多相关教程
大家自行参考操作即可
ok
接下来是构建block controller
block controller是我们提供的一个命令行工具
它可以减化于block的交互
另外强调一下
因为当前seco经向是纪约0.9.3B1Tag打的
这里我先切一下分支
避免编印出来的block controller
比经向更新
然后带来额外的问题
大家操作的时候
建议使用bith hub上面最新的
release tag对应的分支就可以了
然后我这里也提前安装好了
比较新的构
ok
接下来开始构建
大家如果遇到编印上的问题
可能需要自行更新一下构的版本
接下来就是
一些配置的触实化
我们这里会使用setup.sh的脚本来完成
setup.sh这个脚本
它会自动去生成公司药
然后方便我们后面通过dalk
去拉起服务
对于触实化的细节感兴趣的话
大家可以去自行参考文件细节
从这里可以看到
已经
脚本已经自动生成了公司药
以及对应的证书
接下来我们将通过dalk compose来
启动设购服务
为了掩饰方便
我们会拉起Alice
和Bob的
block和engine
在实际的生产环境里面
Alice Bob应该是独立拉起来的
交换公司药之类的配置也会更复杂
具体可以参考我们独立部署的文档说明
ok
这一步操作的话
它是依赖dalk的
然后如果你的环境里面没有dalk的话
也建议提前安装一下
然后再重视这个指令
我们看一下它的启动状态
ok
这里是已经启动了
接下来我们就在
Alice上面创建项目
然后去邀请Bob参加
加入我们的项目
上面这个窗口就是Alice
下面这个就当做Bob吧
然后在我们的dalk compose环境里面
Alice的block是坚定的8081窗口
Bob坚定是8082窗口
ok
那我们先在Alice这边创建项目吧
创建项目成功
接下来我们可以查看一下
项目的具体信息
可以看到项目里面
有它的项目的名称ID
以及项目的创建者
项目的成员
还有配置的项目的一些康复信息
创建完项目之后
我们就可以去邀请其他成员了
这里我们使用的是
broker controller的invite的这个指令
不负这个问题
然后这里我们可以看到Bob接收到了
邀请的信息
Bob如果确认了邀请里面的项目的这个信息
然后ok的话
他就可以来加入这个项目
Bob这里可以看到
也可以看到项目的一些信息
包括项目的名称
创建者
然后
名员以及项目的一些配置
ok
接下来Bob会通过process invitation来
加入这个项目
然后Bob加入项目之后
我们再在Alice这边再看一下
项目信息
这里可以看到成员信息
真新增了一个报告
这样子项目的成员邀请就完成了
邀请完成后
各个项目成员需要根据业务场景
去将数据表注册进项目
并完成授权
我们先完成数据表的创建
Alice会将接一表注册进项目
接一表的话
他有4列
包括ID信用等级
收入 年龄等等
然后这里的reftable和db type
是指的表的实际位置
表示TA表实际对应mySQL数据库里面的
Alice.userCredit表
数据表的注册只是在项目里面建了一个逻辑表
实际的数据还是在实际的表的位置里面
接下来我们看一下表的员信息
ok
Alice这边就把表注册进去了
接下来我们在Bob这边
同样把tb表注册进项目
tb表的话
它也包含ID列
然后还有定当数量以及活跃状态
实际的物理表是Bob.userStatus
我们同样确认一下表的员信息
包括列
以及实际的表的位置
还有这里的owner信息等等
默认情况下
项目成员是没有权限使用数据表里面的数据的
只要表的owner被项目成员进行实际和授权
接下来我们
先完成TA表的授权
TA表的owner是Alice
Alice会先给自己授予所有数据的PlanetX权限
ok
Alice先给自己授予了ID列
ID的rank
这几列的
都给自己授权成了PlanetX权限
接下来他需要给Bob
授予对应列的权限
对于Bob的话
Alice只希望在联合分析的时候
尽量去保护自己的数据安全
因此只授予了必要的这些权限
ID列的话是授予了PlanetX AfterGruBad权限
这样ID列就可以用作journ key
然后Credit列的话
是授予了PlanetX AfterGruBad权限
这样子CreditRank就可以作为GruBad分组列了
然后是Income
是授予了PlanetX AfterGruBad权限
Bob就只能看到Income的聚合信息
包括Average、Mimx之类的
然后Age的话是授予了PlanetX AfterCompare权限
这样子Age列就可以用来做一些数据的过滤
ok
这样子Alice对TA表就完成了授权
接下来是Bob对TB表的授权
同样的Bob先给自己授予了
所有数据的PlanetX权限
然后给Alice授予的权限在这里
Bob给Alice授予了TA表里面
ID列的PlanetX AfterGruBad权限
然后一次Active的话
是授予了PlanetX AfterCompare权限
OrderMount是授予了PlanetX AfterGruBad权限
是授予了PlanetX AfterGruBad权限
两边都授权完成了之后
Alice可以查看自己的CCL授权情况
然后确认一下
Alice拥有TA表的所有列的PlanetX权限
然后拥有TB表的权限
是刚刚Bob授予的这个权限
这里确认一下没有问题
接下来我们再看一下Bob拥有的一些权限
同样Bob他会拥有TB表的所有列的PlanetX权限
然后对于TA表的话
就是Alice给他授予的这一些权限
完成所有配置之后
Alice和Bob就可以
进行联合数据分析任务了
我们从Alice这边作为发起方来发起这个任务
OK 这里我们就完成了数据分析
然后这下面这个打印出来的是分析的结果
要注意的是这里有一个互联信息
这里是为了避免用户通过
min max average之类的操作来反对原始数据
默认情况下我们就会把这种
少于4条的这种Group分组给删除掉
然后如果大家对联合数据分析的具体流程
感兴趣的话也可以通过Block
安装的日制去做进一步的分析
时间关系我这里就不做展开了
OK 以上就是本次课证的全部内容了
最后也欢迎大家实际上手使用设购
参与到我们设购的开源建设中来
甚至在实际场景中应用设购去解决实际的问题
感谢大家的时间
再见